[Musik]
kinder starben die malaria wütete es war
furchtbar die alten und kinder starben
an krankheiten und hunger
viele eltern ließen die leichname ihrer
kinder einfach im wald liegen
[Musik]
addis abeba hauptstadt äthiopiens
menschenmassen versammeln sich an
epiphanias
er ist nur einer von vielen zuschauern
doch er wolle mehr weiß dass die große
mehrheit der feiernden bei der rückkehr
in ihre dörfer armut und leid vorfinden
wird
er glaubt die reichen länder hätten in
afrika versagt die zeit sei reif für
veränderung
ob die reichen länder wohl wenn sie
afrika nicht länger belächeln würden
erkennen könnten dass die bewohner
afrikas den kontinent selbst aus der
armut befreien würden
hunderten milliarden dollar an spenden
und tausender hilfsarbeiter zum trotz
hat sich die lage verschlimmert
er leugnet nicht die korruption
afrikanischer regierungen wirft den
industrieländern jedoch vor dass ihre
hilfe nicht die richtigen menschen
erreiche ich weiß nicht wie viel geld
nach äthiopien kinn
die rede ist von milliarden also halte
ich es für fair auszurechnen wie viel
davon am ziel ankam
das geld floss in verschiedene zwecke
löhne büros in europa hoch bezahlte
helfer aus anderen ländern
ginge das geld direkt an die bauern
könnte das ihr leben verändern
obwohl er kennt die armut er verlor früh
seinen vater seine mutter konnte kaum
seine bildung finanzieren
wir hatten einen kleinen hof
sie tat ihr bestes
um mich zu erziehen
es war schwer darum war sie so
wundervoll
es war nicht einfach damals
ohne vater aufzuwachsen
er fehlte mir als vorbild
je älter er wurde desto mehr frustrierte
ihn die stagnation in der champion
jahrzehntelang blieb das leid seiner
landsleute stets unverändert
er sieht einen großteil der schuld bei
ausländischen behörden
entwicklungs behörden sagen gerne was zu
tun ist
anstatt mit den menschen zu arbeiten
zwingen sie ihnen ihre denkweisen und
ansätze auf
das kann nicht funktionieren
er hinterfragte die logik dahinter in
gebieten ohne gesundheitsversorgung eine
schule zu bauen wo die kinder zu krank
oder zu hungrig waren um sie zu besuchen
wo für die saatgut spenden wenn die
fruchtbare erde weggespült wurde
ihm zufolge sollten außenstehende die
afrikas bedürfnisse nicht verstehen
nicht länger lösungen aufzwingen sondern
die menschen fragen was sie ihrer
meinung nach brauchen
von der außenwelt unbemerkt startete er
vor fünf jahren ein riesiges experiment
ins otto in der mitte äthiopiens
das gebiet dem großen afrikanischen
grabenbruch wird von hungersnöten
heimgesucht hier wollte er eine
viertelmillion menschen überzeugen
kostenlose hilfe abzulehnen und sich
einen eigenen weg aus der armut zu
erarbeiten
er nennt es self help
wir geben nichts umsonst her geschenke
schaffen abhängigkeit
unserer philosophie zufolge muss man
sich selbst helfen wenn man will dass
einem geholfen wird
das ist entscheidend
sein plan war einfach 20 menschen neue
fähigkeiten lehrern die dann ihrerseits
20 weitere anhänger ausbilden die
wiederum 20 anhänger ausbilden immer
weiter mittlerweile hat er zehntausende
anhänger
[Musik]
unsere kameras haben das experiment die
letzten zwei jahre begleitet
[Musik]
wir folgen den geschichten von amine
enthält mologen heile und der
marktstellung
die dort um erfolg ringen wo frühere
generationen scheiterten
andere sind ebenso entschlossen das
experiment zu zerstören um ihre
interessen zu schützen
geldverleiher die ihr geld auf kosten
der armen verdienen sehen ihr geschäft
in gefahr
für mich ist das spiel aus ich habe kaum
noch kunden
diebe schlagen die wenigen verbleibenden
bäume
mauern stehen ihren nachbarn wasser
dazu kommt die rebellion einer
verheerten region in der die männer
nicht ohne kostenlose verpflegung
arbeiten wollen ohne die hilfen sterben
wir
kann er wolle mehler eine gemeinschaft
die seit mehr als einem halben
jahrhundert von ausländischer hilfe
abhängt von der veränderung überzeugen
für einen bruchteil der kosten und ohne
hilfe ausländischer entwicklungshelfer
[Musik]
entgegen der häufigen darstellung sind
weite teile äthiopiens frucht war
insbesondere zur regenzeit
das land sollte normalerweise genug
nahrung für seine bevölkerung
produzieren können
die dürre ist niemals fern
wenn die ernte geht ein nutztiere
verendet
der hunger kehrt zurück
wie viele in soto haben wohl
familienmitglieder an krankheit und
hunger verloren
[Musik]
alle von euch
der hauptgrund der hungersnöte ist die
abhängigkeit von einer pflanzenart
ohne mais sind alle in gefahr
public iso ist ein musterbeispiel
sein leben ist beschwerlich doch bei
einer dürre würde seine familie
monatelang hunger leiden
wir essen morgens mittags und abends
brot
im winter geht auch das nicht
dann wissen wir weniger essen wasser
bekommen wir nur durch regen ohne regen
gibt es keinen mais
als erstes muss der wähler und sein team
der bedrohung durch hungersnot begegnen
die lösung war eine einzige erstaunliche
pflanze
in äthiopien heißt nc die magische
es ist eine der vielseitigsten pflanzen
alles ist verwertbaren
[Musik]
früher wog sie nur im gebirge self help
führte eine hybridform für das flachland
sie benötigt kaum wasser und kann zubrot
klößen und brei verarbeitet werden
aus den blättern kann man seile
herstellen
[Musik]
am wichtigsten ist jedoch ihre
haltbarkeit
sie kann hier sieben jahre lang
vergraben bleiben ohne zu verderben
so ein paket ernährt eine sechsköpfige
familie einen monat lang bei dürre
werden sie ausgegraben und sind nach wie
vor sp
sie gehörten zu den ersten anhängern sie
lernten in säte anzubauen um dem
hungertod zu entgehen
sie wiederum leerten ihre anhänger heute
ist die pflanze in der ganzen region
verbreitet
[Musik]
überleben war das eine doch um die
wirtschaft zu verändern mussten die
bauern mehr nahrung als sie für ihre
familien benötigten und zudem
einträgliche pflanzen anbauen
als kind kümmerte ich mich gern um
pflanzen
es war mein hobby
dann würde ich landwirt und wollte mehr
erreichen
die samen hier in der region waren
allerdings nicht wirklich zu gebrauchen
molo gitta heil lernte als einer der
ersten wie man eine gärtnerei an liegt
bei ihm entstand eine mischung aus
paprika zwiebeln und kaffee die er nun
an nachbarn verkauft
durch die ausbildung sammelte ich viel
erfahrung
sein wissen zu teilen gehört für mologen
zum geschäft
das ist je mehr bauern er ausbildet
desto mehr kaufen seine setzlinge
wir zerschneiden das plastik dann
drücken wir ein wenig erdreich wieder
zurück in das loch
danach sorgen wir wieder für ebenen
boden
das leben war früher hart wir hatten
nichts unsere kinder konnten wir nicht
in die schule schicken
wir konnten keine schulbücher kaufen
wir hatten nicht mal genug geld um auf
den markt zu gehen
stimmt
das verändert sich jetzt doch nicht so
wie man es hier erwartet hätte
bis vor kurzem war so wie fast alle
anderen gebiete vollkommen von männern
dominiert
durch einen auf dem kontinent einmaligen
rollentausch kontrollieren jetzt die
frauen das haushaltseinkommen
es wurde ein spar und kreditprogramm
eine miniatur bank erschaffen und nur
frauen dürfen geld leihen
männer sind wohl nicht mehr
vertrauenswürdig
männer und frauen sind nicht gleich wir
verschwenden kein geld sondern
investieren das zuhause
männer betrinken sich nur sinnlos
von meinem ersten darlehen kaufte und
züchtete ich rinder
was dann zeitig ist zurück vom zweiten
darlehen eröffnete ich das restaurant
meine kinder gehen in die schule
als mologen ag hat die idee für ein
restaurant auf dem land hatte hielt man
sie für verrückt
dadurch das experiment hier jedoch die
einkommen steigen scheint es zu
funktionieren
frauen können geld besser verwalten als
männer
wir strengen uns zu hause an und sind
erfolgreich beim verkauf auf dem markt
wir verdienen anständig
tausende frauen machen mit
kleingeld mit geringen zinsen und kaufen
schafe rinder oder saatgut für ihre
männer die bauern
mit dem gewinn begleichen sie die
schulden und leihen sich mehr um ihre
geschäfte auszuweiten
wenn es jedoch nach dem örtlichen
geldverleihern tarifi kadow ginge hätten
sie nie anfangen sollen
ich gab ihnen einen vertrag und dann am
ende des jahres verlangte ich
schließlich mein geld zurück
wenn jemand nicht zahlen konnte kann
derjenige eben vorbericht
bevor die
nichtregierungsorganisation ankam konnte
ich 100 prozent zinsen verlangen
das ist jetzt vorbei
mario damals eine der ersten am
experiment teil nun lehrt sie ihre
anhänger für sich selbst einzutreten
ich habe viel für meine familie und
nicht bewirkt
vorher kannten wir unsere rechte nicht
durch die treffen wissen wir nun
bescheid jetzt wissen wir wie wir geld
leihen und uns vor der unterdrückung
durch die männer befreien können
ich habe sie vieles gelehrt von der
modernen rinder und hühnerhaltung bis
zum anbau von gemüse papayas und mangos
[Musik]
ich zeigte ihnen auch wie man moderne
bienen stück gebaut
der honig ist gut
[Musik]
jeder bienenstock gibt 40 kilogramm
obwohl ammann es keine formelle bildung
genoss preist sie in die stadt um neue
mittel für die frauen kooperative
auszuhandeln
noch vor ein paar jahren wäre das
undenkbar gewesen
[Musik]
aber richie hat eine tolle
persönlichkeit
sie ist erstaunlich
als wir hier ankamen
waren die meisten frauen scheu
doch diese schicht einheit schwand lang
sein
sollte stolz auf ihre harte arbeit sein
sie gibt ihren kindern chancen
ein besseres ziel gibt es nicht
sie ist schlau und wir haben ähnliche
ansichten
sie ist sogar so schlau dass sich ihr
zutrauen würde alles zu schaffen
sie ermöglicht unseren kindern einen
guten start ins leben
alles was sie tut ist durchdacht
was wollt ihr einmal werden
lehrerin du willst lehrerin werden ja
und du lemm
piloten pilotin ja fantastisch ihr seid
die besten
familienplanung ist ein wichtiger teil
des experiments zum ersten mal seit
langem fällt die geburtenrate in der
region
um ihre ziele zu erreichen müssen die
kinder von amma rich die region jedoch
verlassen
es gibt in der gegend nur eine
grundschule die weiterführende schule
ist 30 kilometer entfernt nur wenige
eltern können sich das leisten
die menschen hier sammeln geld für eine
eigene schule doch noch ist das ein
traum
[Musik]
die fläche für den bau wurde schon
reserviert aber die schule muss noch
warten
[Musik]
im hochnebel auf einem berg in der
region versammeln sich die gläubigen zum
morgengebet
[Musik]
als der nebel sich lüftet er briten wir
eine der verwüsteten regionen äthiopiens
[Musik]
das ist die soko region auch
wasserscheide genannt
in der regenzeit strömen große mengen
wertvollen regenwasser von den bergen
herab und spülen den mutterboden davon
um letztlich ungenutzt in einem fluss zu
wenden
[Musik]
das gebiet mit 1 typischer vegetation
ist heute beinahe eine wüste mehr als
10.000 menschen sind von einem einzigen
brunnen abhängig das wasser muss aus
mindestens 300 metern tiefe hochgepumpt
werden
das gebiet war einst dicht bewaldet mit
der zeit verschwanden die bäume
der mutterboden für den anbau von
pflanzen unerlässlich war der erosion
ausgesetzt
und die bauern konnten keine nahrung
mehr anbauen
es muss sich etwas ändern sowohl e
mailer ist überzeugt dass die bauern es
selbst schaffen müssen
sie kommen aus der ganzen region
zusammen um den strom des wassers
aufzuhalten damit es anschließend
versichert
nur so können sie den grundwasserspiegel
in erreichbare nähe bringen
wie ihr wisst wurde das land in der
region völlig verwüstet
wir müssen daher alle zusammenarbeiten
um es wieder herzustellen
zuerst möchte ich euch allen danken dass
sie heute hier seid noch dazu weil ihr
aus eigenem antrieb gekommen seid
[Applaus]
solon ist jawohl es vertreter an der
wasserscheide
das gebiet wird von wiederkehrenden
fluten und bodenerosion heimgesucht wir
müssen den prozess aufhalten
physische und biologische bewahrung ist
hierbei der schlüssel
auf der physischen seite verhindern wir
die überflutung in dem wir gräben und
stufen errichten
so verhindern wir dass die wasserströme
das erdreich abtragen
auf biologischer seite bedecken wir das
land mit bäumen
die bauern hier pflanzen setzlinge
alle maßnahmen die wir ergreifen sollen
die fruchtbarkeit des bodens verbessern
und die erosion durch die überflutung
verhindern
früher gab es für die arbeit kostenlose
nahrung von anderen hilfsorganisationen
jawohl ist aber entschlossen die
abhängigkeit zu beenden
einige anführer der bauern sind aber
alles andere als glücklich
natürlich ist es beschämend um hilfe zu
bitten
aber wir sind in dieser lage weil wir
arm sind
wir müssen uns fragen warum wir so hart
arbeiten um das land der anderen
umzupflügen
wir werden nicht arbeiten sie sollen uns
weizen geben wie früher
auch für amerika und die anderen
vertreter des spar-und kreditmodell es
läuft es nicht gut
einige frauen konnten das geliehene geld
nicht zurückzahlen
das gremium was einen aufschub gewähren
oder sie vor gericht stellen
tun sie nichts könnte es nachahmer
inspirieren
warum sind die schulden nicht beglichen
also eine gast
warum bist du im verzug
ich habe daran gearbeitet das darlehen
abzubezahlen
meine kinder haben mit der schule
angefangen aber mein haus drohte
einzustürzen
darum habe ich es mit dem kredit
repariert
wir gaben die den kredit damit du ein
kleines unternehmen gründen und ein
einkommen verbessern könnte
der kredit war für keinen anderen zweck
bestimmt wie zum beispiel dem
wiederaufbau seines hauses
deine antwort ist inakzeptabel
[Musik]
es war ein fehler von ihr das geld für
ihr haus zu verwenden
sie muss jetzt die zahlungen vornehmen
sonst ergreifen wie rechtliche schritte
als die anderen ihre säumigkeit
begründen offenbart sich die spaltung
des gremiums
meine geschäfte liefen gut
aber dann würde mein kind schwer krank
ich hatte das geld und musste eine
schwere entscheidung treffen
ich nutze das also für die
behandlungskosten meines kindes
zeit für eine entscheidung
das gremium hat die situation bewertet
und setzt eine neue frist
die schulden der willigen ein bei
verspäteter zahlung zusätzlicher 100
würfe gerichtskosten und 150 bier an das
gremium zu entrichten
zugesichert durch unterschrift
sie erhalten weitere drei monate zeit
halten sie die frist nicht ein drohen
gerichtliche folgen sie alle müssen
unterzeichnen
es gibt viele gründe warum sie das
wenige geld das sie haben so streng
überwachen auch abseits der finanzierung
von schulen und anderen wichtigen
projekten
sollen und gäbe ist seit kurzem leiter
der neuen klinik im ort keller
sie ist die erste ihrer art und kümmert
sich um 40.000 menschen ins otto
früher mussten diese patienten 20
kilometer laufen um behandelt zu werden
[Musik]
die gemeinschaft steuert geld und
arbeitskräfte bei
den menschen gefällt es sehr jederzeit
behandlung bekommen zu können
sie sehen die klinik auch als ihre
klinik
[Musik]
bevor die klinik entstand war man hier
von arzneimittel verkäufern abhängig die
oft das zehnfache verlangten
in ihrer eigenen apotheke bekommen sie
sie nun fast ohne aufpreis
auch das krankenhaus der region wurde
von der bevölkerung selbst errichtet
als feldherr kamen trafen sie eine
vereinbarung mit der lokalregierung die
bevölkerung stellt geld und arbeit für
den bau von schulen und krankenhäusern
die behörden zahlen personal und
unterhalt
weil es kein krankenhaus gab mussten die
menschen früher 150 kilometer nach adis
oder 100 kilometer nach rosana
sie können sich vorstellen dass die
versorgungslage damals ein großes
problem war
mehr als eine million menschen auch von
außerhalb des ellfeldt bereichs können
nun die anlage nutzen
die schlimmsten krankheiten hier sind
atemwegsinfektionen tuberkulose
lungenentzündungen malaria
malaria ist fast im ganzen flachland
verbreitet
das engagement der gemeinschaft gab uns
die energie des krankenhaus zu errichten
das jetzt wiederum der gemeinschaft
dient
das krankenhaus funktioniert aber
anderswo in soto läuft nicht alles nach
plan
[Musik]
das projekt an der wasserscheide ist in
gefahr
vor nur 18 monaten lag der
grundwasserspiegel 300 meter unter der
erde
sie gruben dämme und furchen damit das
regenwasser versickert und das
grundwasser steigt
das grundwasser ist auf 30 meter
gestiegen
mit der zeit wird das wasser weiter bis
auf zehn oder fünfzehn meter steigen so
dass es für bauern einfach zugänglich
wird
vor beginn des projektes bekamen die
bauern für jede arbeit kostenlose
nahrung aus amerika oder kanada
wohle will dass sie ohne geschenke
arbeiten
sind damit einverstanden
sie arbeiten hart manche bauern aber
machen probleme sagen die anderen
sollten nicht ohne
nahrungsmittellieferungen arbeiten der
bauern rat hat ein treffen einberufen er
wohl erscheint mit seinem team
einige rebellieren sie sind es gewohnt
weizen für ihre arbeit zu bekommen du
musst erklären dass das land zur wüste
wird und sie antreiben wieder zu
arbeiten
wir arbeiten hier umsonst früher wurden
wir für unsere arbeit bezahlt jetzt
bekommen wir nichts warum sollten wir
umsonst arbeiten bis das problem gelöst
ist wenn uns die organisation weizen
geben kann wir verweigern die arbeit
der anführer der rebellion djemba dahne
kam nicht zur versammlung
wir wollen sofort unseren lohn darum
wollen wir nicht arbeiten
ohne diese belohnung haben wir kein
interesse
seine ablehnung ist verständlich so sera
wohle und sein team betreuen das
grundwasser steige in der einöde um sein
zuhause kann er nichts davon erkennen
die entwicklungshilfe wird uns nicht
ewig an ihre
welche optionen bleiben uns
wenn wir nicht wollen dass das land zur
wüste wird und unsere kinder leiden
müssen wir die umwelt ändern
wenn wir nicht umgehend handeln wird
dass hier eine wüste und nicht überlebt
einige bauern sprechen sich für melas
plan aus
was passiert wenn der weizen der
entwicklungshilfe wegfällt wir werden
sterben
wir können nicht warten nun nichts tun
wir müssen arbeiten wir alle
das treffen endet ohne ergebnis
[Musik]
bemba deines protest sich ausweitet
gerät das ganze projekt in gefahr
[Musik]
es war amine nt lhe der sich für den
verzicht auf entwicklungshilfe
ausgesprochen hat
sie sind es gewohnt den weizen geschenkt
zu bekommen
dadurch würden sie abhängig davon
vor projektbeginn lebte ich noch nicht
einmal hier
ich war tagelöhner und verdiente 3 bis
etwa 30 cent am tag
es lebt niemand hier es war nur ein tal
ohne straßen
nicht einmal esel und rinder konnten
hier herkommen wir sind nur dank des
schutts projektes hier
früher konnte man in der region kaum
gemüse anbauen wir hatten nur mais und
hirse
wohle ist sicher arbeiten die bauern an
der wasserscheide zusammen werden sie
ebenso erfolgreich wie andere
in der ganzen region entstehen
kooperativen
bevor self help ein bewässerungssystem
installierte lag das land hier brach
[Musik]
wir verdienen unseren lebensunterhalt
als bauern uns geht es jetzt viel besser
als früher
auch unsere ernährung ist jetzt besser
und gesünder geworden
wir bauen kartoffeln tomaten und
zwiebeln an
und verkaufen sie auf dem markt so leben
wir
nach so kam wuchsen bei jedem bauern
vielleicht 100 kilogramm zwiebeln
[Musik]
jetzt schaffen wir bis zu zwei tonnen
alles dank der hilfe und der ratschläge
die wir erhielten
noch ehe man sich in der zentrale von
self help mit der rebellion an der
wasserscheide befassen kann beginnt
schon die nächste krise
wir haben ein problem einige bauern
stehlen wasser von anderen bauern da
müssen wir umgehend einschreiten wenn
wir das problem nicht lösen führt das zu
weiteren problemen
das bewässerungssystem sollte den ertrag
vieler bauern maximieren auch in der
trockenzeit
es hat nicht nur die landschaft sondern
auch das leben der bewohner verändert
ein mitglied der kooperative leitet
scheinbar heimlich meerwasser auf seine
eigenen feld hat
für außenstehende wirkt es banal aber
hier geht es ums überleben
wieder einmal muss a wohle vermitteln
dort wird bewässert jetzt nicht mehr wer
hat es gestohlen er dort eher gehen wir
hin
einige wollen die polizei rufen andere
werden aggressiv
warum spielst du was meine zwiebeln
verbrennen die anderen halten sich an
den plan was ist dein problem
es gibt einen zeitplan für das wasser
ganz ruhig reden wir lieber im schatten
drüben
warum spielst du wasser
weil mein gemüse in der hitze eingeht
denkst du das geht uns dann anders
was soll ich sonst tun mein gemüse geht
ein
warte bis du dran ist
die anderen wollen ihn vom bewässerten
land werfen
die kooperative hat den menschen hier
leben geschenkt wird jemand rausgeworfen
verliert er alle privilegien der
gemeindemitglieder und fällt wieder in
die arme zurück das ist die schlimmste
strafe für ihn
das hier ist der dreh und angelpunkt den
teil die gesamte region wurde von
einzelnen unternehmern und bauern in
kooperativen verwandelt
das durchschnittseinkommen hat sich
vervierfacht überall werden exotische
waren angeboten die man hier zuvor fast
nie sah
[Musik]
mit auch ein steuereintreiber ist
gekommen
wer nicht teil des projekts ist kann
davon nur träumen
zurück zur bowle chiesa dessen familie
von wasser und brot lebt
sie leben buchstäblich auf der falschen
straßenseite der hof von hat der graf
auf der anderen straßenseite liegt
gerade noch im bereich von self help
auch er lebte einst von wasser und brot
doch nun baut er zwiebeln paprika
kartoffeln und eine mischung lukrativer
pflanzen an dir auf dem markt verkauft
vom gewinn ließ er ein wasserloch in
seinen feldern errichten damit auch eine
heftige dürre seine ernte nicht zerstört
seiner familie geht es gut seine kinder
gehen in die schule
wie millionen afrikaner sehen sich auch
aktuelle nach dieser chance
gebe man mir diese gelegenheit mein
leben so zu ändern würde ich es tun
wer bin ich gesund und stark
self help wird das projekt bald
ausweiten und abdullah will unbedingt
mit dabei sein
es geht nicht nur um überleben sondern
auch um stolz
ich will diese chance wirklich nutzen
hätte ich die gleichen chancen ginge es
mir jetzt viel besser ich könnte die
gute kleidung tragen
ich habe große hoffnungen ich will ein
haus bauen und meiner familie neue
kleidung kaufen können
ich könnte ochsen auf dem hof nutzen
meiner familie besseres essen und mehr
sauberkeit ermöglichen
im gegensatz dazu konnte am markt studio
den gewinn den sie mit ihrer ernte
erzielt hat für den bau eines brunnens
in ihrem garten nutzen voller stolz
zeigt sie in ihren 20 anhängern
litten an verschiedenen krankheiten
verursacht von schlechtem wasser das
nicht sauber war
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir sie alle überwunden und
müssen uns weniger oft in ärztliche
behandlung begeben
[Musik]
auch das restaurant der heillos erlebt
veränderungen
das neue dach ist fertig neue möbel sind
bestellt und der für die region übliche
lehmboden wird durch festen zement er
selbst
[Musik]
fabry head und ihren mann nur logica hat
sich das leben völlig gewandelt
dieses paar wartet stets geduldig auf
große ereignisse
weißt du noch wie du lange nach unserer
hochzeit dein erstes kind bekommen hast
die haare das war vor sieben jahren
zuerst kam er
dann vier kinderlose jahre und dann
ilias
es hat sich viel verändert aber du bist
glücklich ja
unser leben ist jetzt viel besser
sie sind ein großartiges ehepaar
wirklich sie sind ein leuchtendes
beispiel für die gemeinde ihren weg aus
der armut verfolgen konnte
sie haben gezeigt dass man aus der armut
ausbrechen kann wenn man hart daran
arbeitet
auch die kinder der region haben grund
zur freude
heute ist ein stolzer tag für die
menschen in soto
[Applaus]
tausende sind gekommen denn endlich
wurde genug geld gesammelt um den
grundstein für ein besonderes gebäude zu
legen
der baum der weiterführenden schule
beginnt
mehr als drei jahre lang sammelten sie
geld durch den verkauf ihrer ernte die
kleider herstellung und direkte spenden
der bewohner
sie selbst haben es vollbracht nun sehen
sie endlich die früchte ihrer arbeit
was für ein großartiger tag für uns alle
es freut mich wie viele gekommen sind
aber
[Musik]
nicht alle haben grund zu feiern
nach drei monaten konnten zwei der sechs
frauen ihre schulden bei der frauen
kooperative nicht innerhalb der neuen
frist begleichen
roger dem easy eröffnete mit dem
geliehenen geld ein restaurant um ihre
kinder zu versorgen von denen eines eine
behinderung hat
eine frist ist abgelaufen
familie erst überhaupt zweier haushalte
dass es schwer für ihn da kann man
finanziell darum nur wenig helfen
kann müller verkaufte erfolgreich waren
auf dem markt bevor ihr mann sie und
ihre kinder nach einem streit aus dem
haus werfen
ich war ein jahr lang obdachlos konnte
meine kinder nicht ernähren
dafür nutzte ich den kredit ist das geld
weg war
ich habe nichts mehr niemand ernährt
meine kinder oder zahlt für ihre
ausbildung
die wurden vor dass schulden gremium
berufen
bei unserem letzten treffen sagte tier
würde die schulden begleichen
das habt ihr hier so unterschrieben
wieder ist das studio besorgt andere
würden nicht bezahlen wenn das gremium
nicht hart bleibt
wenn sie das geld haben ist alles gut
wenn nicht
sollten wir vor gericht gehen um das
geld zurückzubekommen
bei den frauen drohen rechtliche
schritte ihre kinder müssen womöglich
aus der schule und landen auf der straße
denn man einigt sich dann auf einen
letzten kompromiss sie bekommen noch
zwei monate aber nur wenn sie einen
weiteren garantiegeber für ihre schulden
finden
ich freue mich sehr darüber
ich möchte der vereinigung von herzen
für ihr verständnis mir gegenüber danken
[Musik]
an der wasserscheide trägt die vor der
rebellion getaner arbeit früchte
überall im flachland entsteht grüne
vegetation
[Musik]
volumina versucht unermüdlich die bauern
zurückzugewinnen
er bemerkt dass die rädelsführer nicht
gekommen sind
die anwesenden hingegen wirken
entschlossen auch ohne sie
weiterzumachen
ich hätte wegen wichtiger geschäfte weg
gemusst aber dieses treffen konnte ich
nicht verpassen ich sehe gewaltigen
fortschritt insbesondere in der rückkehr
der grünen flecken
wurde betont noch einmal dass die
zukunft allein in ihren händen liegt
wenn ihr nicht zusammenarbeitet werden
das land und der boden wieder weggespült
wenn wir das nicht aufhalten wird die
gegend zu einer vollkommenen wüste und
absolut unbrauchbar
dann könnt ihr hier nicht mehr erleben
die rädelsführer schweigen doch hunderte
sind gekommen um die nächsten gräben
gegen die fluten auszuheben
denn dann erklimmen unvermittelt demba
danne und die anderen möchtegern
rebellenführer den hang und sie haben
ihr werkzeug mitgebracht
ich habe erkannt dass die schädlichen
auswirkungen hier uns alle in die armut
getrieben haben um einer gemeinde zu
helfen muss ich an mir selbst arbeiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
ohne einen einzigen entwicklungshelfer
und für einen bruchteil der kosten eines
vergleichbar umfangreichen projekts
ergreifen nahezu eine viertelmillion
menschen in afrika die gelegenheit beim
schopf sich aus der extremen armut zu
befreien
die märkte quellen vor waren über und
eine neue unternehmer generation baut
auf die zukunft
[Musik]
neu entstandene schulen geben den
jüngsten höhere ziele
kliniken verbessern das gesundheitswesen
der region
selbst der hunger ist dank der
einführung eine nahezu magischen pflanze
viel weniger bedrohlich
afrikaner helfen afrikanern
nachbarn helfen nachbarn
die menschen sind voller stolz ihr
schicksal wieder selbst in die hand zu
nehmen
jenseits der grenzen von self help
jedoch ist die armut weiter unübersehbar
[Musik]
die menschen hier fragen sich
was wird aus uns
[Musik]
afrika kann seine probleme selbst lösen
[Applaus]
[Musik]